[Music]
[Applause]
but like van washing I would even go as
far to say I was kind of like religious
cult you're taking people's money but
you're not giving him the services
you've probably split up if they hadn't
have encouraged him then maybe it'd
still be here hey everyone welcome to
coffee Zillah today we have a special
episode it's a little bit solemn as
you'll see because we're talking about a
very serious situation and that is of
Danny butcher his family and Samuel
Leeds and the course that he sells
before we get into everything I just
want to say for a second that I've been
talking for a very long time about the
predatory aspect of fake gurus of wealth
creation courses and that they pander to
people who are in desperate desperate
situations and that that often leads to
very bad circumstances which these gurus
like to ignore they like to gloss over
and they like to pretend doesn't exist
in their glossy testimonials and
avoidance of frankly their students that
do not perform we've talked to Garrett
who lost $26,000 on this program we've
talked to Anthony who lost $50,000 we've
talked to people who lost $20,000 we've
talked to people all across the spectrum
of losing everything from $2,000 to
entire life savings but today we're
talking to a family who lost the most
important thing of all which is the life
of Danny butcher he took Samuels course
he got in debt and ultimately he took
his own life so with that I want to
welcome the people who bravely came on
the show today obviously this is very
tragic so I appreciate you guys taking
the time to talk with me about it today
we have from I guess we'll go right to
left we have Kerry we have Glen and we
have Alan Kerry is Danny
Glynn is his brother-in-law and Alan is
his father thank you guys for coming on
so I guess we'll start at the beginning
of the beginning of the end I guess
which is when Danny started his course
or maybe a bit before that Danny
served in the military from what I
understand correct
can you guys kind of walk me through how
everything happened because this is sort
of the ultimate tragedy and tell me from
your perspectives what happened with
Danny okay and well Danny has obviously
his son he'd said he's only just got
married 11 weeks before he died and he
was trying to progress so he could buy a
place earn some decent money for him and
his wife and his son and he
he just want you to be able to provide
decently for them not be a millionaire
not be greedy just wanted to be sitting
comfortable for him and have something
for them and that's all he wanted that
he's literally all he wanted he had a
few problems with the debt before but
when he went on the course they were
saying you know we can eat we can get
where you can pay off your all your
debts you can end up we earn lots of
money lots of properties and go from
there so we fought or gray I can I can
pay these debts off I can find home for
us I can provide from family and when he
went on these courses he didn't get away
promise it was promised the thing finish
wasn't about read where they like their
Danny was it was a reserve so he was off
when the army every now and again which
was more with the army than it was
civilian life but he was already driving
at a time
and he started doing some internet
browsing and he heard about this
simulates in these courses
and I know one who doesn't understand
Samuel Leeds is one of these guys you
know promising fast success with with
the course and in his case it is a
variant of what they're all promising
which is wealth and he was offering a
property a property course is that
correct yeah yeah he was he was offering
property called education basically
about how you can go about things and
Dani thought we'd done doing due
diligence as I call it but there was
nothing to say on Trustpilot
at the time that this particular bloke
their problems with his students
so I've done it for he'd done everything
correct he wasn't expecting overnight
well for anybody even said to me this is
a fifteen or twenty year thing he's got
in mind of doing and then he goes in
hundred percent to everything he ever
did he always put hundred percent and he
basically believe what I told him and
in the end he's realized they weren't
giving him the training they weren't
given the mentorship they had said
though and he actually wrote the story
about his involvement with it which is
anybody that's been thinking about it
should read
Danny's story and it had so he exactly
these things just go wrong
now you don't get the one-to-one
mentorship or anything like that and
that led on to other things that cause
done his biggest problem which was he
ended up in a position where he couldn't
get a nurse where his wife and kid right
so talk me through that so he he's
taking the course he's optimistic he
thinks he's done his due diligence
because on the internet it's actually
surprisingly easy to manufacture social
proof and hide criticisms and so he
thinks he thinks he's done his due
diligence so he goes to this thing he
signs up do you do you remember how much
it cost him to sign up for the course
for me because he actually went with him
yes
the course is twelve thousand pounds to
sign up if you pay in full there than
that but Danny can't afford to pay the
full price in one go so he did it over a
few installments and well because I went
to the crash course with him well we
were there on one of the breaks he went
on to his banking app managed to take
out a loan from the bank to go and pay
for the first installment so the first
the first installment of paying for this
thing he's already in debt yeah
Nevada and he then goes to the back of
the room which is where they asked them
alter - boom - the back you know it's
like only the first 50 there and all
that lot they run to the back of the
room he asked if he can still go on it
and will he be able to pay for his next
installment he has to do a deal to be
able to afford to do his next
installment so which he was told
yeah it's absolutely no problem we'll
get you sorted get you a deal for your
next payment for your next so you can
pay your next installment of the course
so he's already like needing I mean he's
showing all the signs of someone who
should not be allowed to join a course
like this that there should be
regulations against joining a course
like this because the whole thing is
that they say the whole logic is well
you're gonna make so much money in the
backend that the cost of the course is
nothing that's what you're convinced to
believe but the reality is is if you put
yourself in that position what happens
if it fail if it fails these people take
know that the the peoples on these
courses take no accountability for that
well they the other thing that happen
because he's going to the back they they
knew that he'd taken out a loan to pay
for the first installment they never
asked him any questions about whether he
could afford it what they also knew that
he can't afford the next installment
unless he did this deal right so he they
say yeah sign up sign up sign up so he
goes in that first installment he's
already in debt and then he has to make
this deal happen
so I imagine that puts him under an
enormous amount of stress to try to make
this safe life for him and his family
his new family so what happens at that
point
certainly after age he'd actually got
he'd been out viewing houses he's
talking to people before we even went on
the course and it got several deals that
he could source and pass on and make
some money out of already set up we were
I know we were told on the crash course
that the deals could be put through a
leaflet allister's company I started no
this is all also been said online yeah
because if Danny wasn't compliant to do
deal sorting so they said because he
wasn't compliant they could play through
allister's company and then Danny could
get paid out of that so basically don't
worry about the fact you're not
compliant we'll figure it out for you we
have some a way for you to do this just
exactly okay then what happens is they
backtrack on that and say no you can
only do that if you come along to
another course and get yourself
compliant
yeah just did it upsell into something
else now you got to pay more money
12,000 pounds wasn't wasn't enough so he
lost them deals couldn't do anything we
lost them deals so he lost the deals at
this point he knows now he's paid this
first installment he's gotten alone he's
worse in a worse place than when he
started
what what's the date on this when is
when was this where are we at
it's March when he signed up right then
he wanted to go to pay for the next lot
of deals it was for next installments he
wanted to need the deals so he went he
messaged everybody the possibly message
tried to get him with all the people
that were with Samuel his messaged
everybody you know how can I improve
what can I do
can i what about this deal what about
that deal is literally message everybody
can possibly say to basically say I'm
actually there and I want to progress I
want to do it right I want to put in the
work exactly
and but obviously that deal never came
up along so then his next installment he
had to get another loan out to pay for
that and then he's third installment he
couldn't pay again so when he went back
to the bank they said no because he'd
Audio got to loans that in such a short
period of time
history's wife ended up having to get
the third lot of installment out for him
and in the middle of all this he was
supposed to go on the deal find an
extravaganza course where there it says
in the crash course that you're supposed
to be guaranteed to get a deal by the
end of the day
and he never did so that that's just not
true
no the second caution it's not just
Danny there's quite a few people been
annoyed and said you go up with second
course and it's but basically the same
as the crash course which is free yeah
so they they're really not getting any
help at all and I mean while they're
plunging into debt oh yeah yeah so then
they go back again and I said well yeah
but to do that you need discourse so
then he gets in the third and this is
just the lining Samuel leads pockets
here oh yeah yeah yeah I mean that's
that that's the winner of this situation
so Danny goes I believe he went a total
of how much in debt during this process
of becoming wealthy as he thought he was
how much how much in debt was he
ultimately when we've looked at it he
paid thirteen and a half because they
charged a 1500 pound for the privilege
of playing in [ __ ] right so if you
can't afford it you have to pay more
yeah and then irony because of the
travelling round and everything he's
done to the cold seas and hotels and
everything else he comes up to close 18
grand
eighteen thirteen thousand pounds and in
the meantime that was actually inviting
him to other courses to help mentor
other people yeah exactly
he was told to mentor other people even
though he's just realized in today yeah
he was supposed to Oprah and get deals
and yet I wouldn't have a clearly get a
deal but of course he can't help them
get there was no qualifier yeah he he in
fact I honestly that makes me speechless
I'm actually speechless at that
now Danny at this point you know he's
just gotten married
he's got you I believe you said he has a
son yeah he finds himself going from
wanting from basically ground the ground
floor thinking well I can't get worse
let me pull myself up and trust one of
these people and finds himself now in
the hole 18,000 pounds no off no better
off than he was before
and he's just feels helpless he feels
like there's no way out well dude the
worst thing about ISM he's doing this
all to try and make a home for his
family right then to find that he can't
get a home because now I obviously can't
get a mortgage
he can't borrow any money to boil rice
he's just done a which way to turn there
and I think that probably you know he
the penny it was dropping because he
wrote a story and it's so we'll wrote
from someone who's dyslexic
you got a understand a grammar not might
not be great but it's a hell of a story
two ways right now yeah to total despair
I think that I've heard this situation
not just from Danny but from multiple
people about when they get in this kind
of debt and all they wanted to do was
get themselves out of debt yeah
that leads to despair more than just
normally getting in debt does because
you feel like you've done everything you
possibly can
and this ultimately brings us to October
I guess yeah
when did you guys first hear the news do
you guys do you guys remember seeing
signs I mean was it like was he talking
about being in debt in Samuels course I
spoke to him
couple of days before I went and had a
look another are you still trying out
when you say will you come and have a
look at this building dead cuz up being
a joiner I've got some knowledge II
might not event we went under today
it didn't look well
I still don't think he'd do anything
right there and we arranged to meet on
the monday but he had another hotel you
wanted me to look at for other investors
what so he supposedly was going to get
paid from them but doing the legwork for
him doing a survey as such
[Music]
and on the Sunday
the police come Clara has to tell us
Dani gone
so yeah if you think about
retrospectively the signs are there
but you don't you just don't see it you
just think he was still I spoke to him
on the Saturday he was driving on yeah
and he was right beast it's all dead Oh
God for coming to conclusion though I
think you know it's gonna take me a
couple of years to get straight but
we'll be away
and he sounded a bit upbeat and that was
on the Saturday and then obviously
somebody morning he was gone
it's just that you just don't you just
don't really see it coming
everybody says a lot of people have been
in touch with us I have been in a
similar situation or close to and
they've all said the same you never see
it at me you never see it coming
do you think that Samuel Leeds knows
what he's done
how you don't care about
yes no he's never once try to contact us
in any way to make any sort of you know
in touch with us in any way or for his
wife any words of comfort of any soul
just the opposite really
he didn't he didn't
he didn't pay back the the money Danny
paid him now there's things on the
internet now where he is fine a lot of
people wore the similar problems is
going to Coppa no souls no blame I hate
I hate to cut to the chase but do you
blame Samuel Leeds because we'll never
we'll never know for sure but in your
minds you guys were so close to this
situation
do you blame Samuel leads for what
happened to Daniel bring the sort of
businesses running yet
I said blind to other people's favorite
Sesto he's a narcissist but I'd
certainly blame his his tactics of way
runs a business but it's not just in
there are a lot of people out there
doing the same rubbish absolutely I mean
that and that's something that my
channels built on trying to stop is this
predatory course selling I say it all
the time
I call it predatory because I believe it
is cuz it preys on those who are weak
and vulnerable and you know I think some
people think that oh if you fall for
that but the thing is is that it's easy
to say I wouldn't fall for that when
you're not struggling when you're not in
debt when you're not back against the
wall and I think this is such a tempt
because there's no regulation these
people can just kind of promise anything
they can promise anything and they don't
get held accountable so something that
impressed me about you know
the response to Danny situation
something that you know obviously this
can never be turned into a positive
thing but one thing that I saw in the
fundraiser was that you guys want to see
regulation happen in this industry you
want to see a change so that it doesn't
happen to anyone else
oh yeah yeah absolutely I mean there's
been loads of people in touch with this
some have actually said they was close
to the position Danny was he I'm reading
his story actually slept on out of it if
you know there's another soldier and and
reveal but believe his name similar
things and he quotes exactly the same
sort of thing as Danny told us exactly
but there's thousands now involved and
that's that's really all we can do for
Danny is push for regulation to stop
this sort of scamming if you like I
don't know what other words you would
call it I like that word
set up a position to try and get it
regulated this kind of thing over here
in the UK I'd be nice if it went more
worldwide but you know we've saw a
position here to try and get it
regulated I'll link that what is what is
the petition do you know the web address
consent that's fine for everyone
watching it'll be in the link below is
is Danny butcher's Widow still in debt
from this whole thing no okay no be
pushin thousands of people actually come
forward and put money in the pot and
paid it off
or
what the bank has written off
so through the kindness of other page
put a zero debt
and they were together when in that
position that would never ever happen
you know it with we're really grateful
for the source of poll yeah I'm I'm also
grateful for that yeah I didn't I didn't
know the full status because I was
looking at the the fundraisers I was
trying to keep keep up with that as well
so I'm glad to hear that
yeah people stepped up and you know this
is such a tough situation for me because
on the one hand you wanna
honor the memory and you also want to
inspire change what tangible things can
you see guys see changing in the wealth
creation industry you might call it is
it the promises is it the cost what is
it that you want to see change
of me personally I'd like to see the
content of the courses looked into to
see that they are providing what the
same provided because from what I've
seen that Danny got from Samuel leaders
course there was very little course
content that hadn't been gone over in in
the class B 3 class course that I'd been
to
no relief for people should be able to
go in and see what they'll actually
teaching pretty much like most education
places over here do right don't hide the
one wealth secret or whatever they're
saying you have to be able to kind of
batter up what you're saying yeah prove
it yeah there needs to be a standard of
times you go university or school
there's standards that they have to keep
- and you go to university you pay money
and yes you have a debt but you've
reached speed education that should
would God will open up other doors for
you to pay for an education you don't
receive is ludicrous
so with regulating you can play right if
you can't go and tell you that you're
going to actually show what education
you're going to get you can't operate
to protect from scammers
I totally agree what one tragic thing
about this is that the victims of these
scams tend to be poor they tend to be
[Music]
they don't have like legislative tools
at their disposal if this was happening
to a bunch of rich people you know this
would have been legislated out of
existence a long time ago but it feels
like especially here I'm more ameno
aware of the American situation you know
a lot of times these people say well if
they didn't like my course so much why
don't they just sue me like the Guru or
whoever will say that and the answer is
always well they don't have money to do
it and you have to pay to sue and they
they have all your money now you're in
debt you don't even have any recourse to
going after and getting your money back
I mean what gets me is that you consult
a $12,000 course and have nothing to
show for it and you can Excel to it to
somebody who has
no money to pay for it that is mind
blowing that you can put someone deep in
debt who has nothing going right now and
you can promise them the world and
you're not held accountable
at all now
is Samuel Leeds still doing business in
the UK yeah yeah and he's not changed
one iota of his methods in fact he he is
there are a lot of pressure among from
the internet where because I say there
was so many flipping on forward since
Danny's death and saying they've
suffered the same thing but a lot of
people wear the MIT they've got it got
ripped off so they don't come forward
well since Danny's death I love a lot
people with and it is going to cope with
what I call the class action and that's
a number of paid for I don't know where
you say in in the state I call it a
class action as well yeah okay today you
know exactly what my hmm that's going
forward and hopefully that will go
forward on other people were doing the
same thing for old people realize they
don't need to be embarrassed
they need to stand up and get their
getting money back or get value for
their money
how does it how does it feel to know
that Samuel Leeds is still doing the
exact same thing he's been doing and
he's still operating the exact same way
I I can't imagine I can't imagine
I saw had to say on there we just goes
to show he has no remorse or it's
actually done
I hope that someone who sells a course
sees this and rethinks who they're
targeting with their course because I
mean I I'll just tell you guys I've seen
a lot of stuff I've seen people
admitting privately that they are
targeting poor people I mean I've seen a
lot of insane stuff but to have this
happen whether or not Samuel wants to
say that it's his fault whether he
believes that or not but to have this
happen with your course and then to not
to keep doing it is unconscionable in my
opinion it's completely unconscionable
well I hope that you guys get the change
and the justice that you deserve
obviously there may not be a way to get
that perfect justice but my hope is that
Danny's you know untimely end will have
inspired change in this industry I don't
know what it takes to wake wake this
stuff up because like I said at the
beginning fortunes have been lost I've
watched people their entire fortune is
gone what they saved up for years is
gone because of these people and
nothing's changing I don't know what
it's gonna take this is this is it
yeah well this bus we've had an enormous
amount of support from people in the
industry actually but no not operating
there it was game side of it if I could
play that way one particular where
Andrew Burgess go in touch with us
almost by the way and he was a driving
force of helping Danny's widow Charlotte
out and got people to put money together
and solve it her you know being for
financially if you like
I've got messes of information on so
many ways and quite a few others he's
quite knowledgeable
I believe he's run a few videos about
Samuel as well right here
I'll link your fuses below him he's also
push we've started a registered charity
in Danny's name an axe - well I've rear
the arm reversed wet burns and any other
what we think that deserving charities
so as we get money in as deserving
charity that was actually think we can
Oh Annie's 100 trustees along with
myself and caring so that's that all the
work in between your net to you know be
registered has been through it he's been
brilliant can't thank give me enough to
be honest I'm glad you shouted them out
yeah yeah we were swell were in touch
with absolutely we'll be linking the
charity as well if you want to send me
that link Kerry yeah and I don't know is
there anything else you guys wanted to
say I didn't want to make this you know
super long I didn't want to sort of
labor it I wanted to get Danny story out
there and I wanted to get the family
story out there obviously you guys are
sort of his living memory so is there
anything else you guys wanted to say
no no just help us make it may take more
than anything we need to regulate you
face that's their be all and end all at
my money valued anything we can do for
Danny now is to push for that regulation
and hopefully stop anybody else get into
that situation no that's a said thank
you to you for allowing us to get it out
there okay
absolutely I'm happy to do it
I know this this has been a long time in
the making and yeah I really I thank you
guys for coming on thanks to all of you
who are watching sorry that it was a
very solemn but I think it's important
as we look at this industry that we show
the very damaging sides the predatory
sides of this industry so thanks for
watching everybody